bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur sur des
modèles tv coupe du monde fis dès 2017
16e de finale on va voir les départage
donc maxime qui n'a pas réussi à faire
mieux que deux parties du même face à
l'aine dorman ils restent favoris donc
mais il est poussé au départage donc ça
se joue en partie rapide 20 minutes par
joueur
plus 10 secondes parcours puis ensuite
il ya deux parties en cas de nouvelle
égalité de dix minutes plus 2 secondes
par coup et enfin on aura des blitz 5 +
3 et éventuellement le fameux blitz
armageddon finale où les blancs doivent
absolument l'emporter
les noirs peuvent se qualifier en
faisant uniquement match nul dans ce
dernier blitz
mais les blancs aurait dans ce cas là
une minute de plus on n'en est pas là
d'abord les parties rapides bien entendu
maxime allais noir donc face à face à
dender man c'est parti première partie
rapide pour ce pour ce résumé de la
journée vous allez voir pour länder man
avec cavaliers f3 carrière 3 août à fait
normal rien de spécial ces cinq c4 donc
type type anglais un peu pour l'instant
cavalier c6 des quatre reprises prise
cavaliers m6 car les c3 et après eux six
les blancs jouent à 3 il empêche le fou
de venir en b 4 dont il n'y a pas de
clouage possible du cavalier fawcett et
e4 donc là on a transposé dans une sorte
de deux sicilienne avec le fameux et o2
maroc 6 6 4 et ccnq voilà anglaise qui
permet de varier
ça permettra de transformer souvent
gambie dame soit on sicilienne comme ici
plusieurs plusieurs possibilités petit
rock et kf3 donc ce set et thomas roxy
ici avec ses deux pions qui contrôle la
casse des 5 ce qui rend très difficile
la poussée libératrice des noirs des
cinq dames c'est 7
fuhe 2b 6 voilà il n'ya plus que le fou
à sortir
voilà donc qui va le sortir maxime
prépetit rock voilà faut baisser est
terminée on a rockets on a lié les tours
toutes les personnes développer pas de
problème pour les noirs et pour les
blancs voilà il restait que le pousser à
sortir puis la dame faudra quand même
bouger la dame est en fait les tours
pour en revenir en jeu et les blancs une
petite pression au sein de grâce à ses
deux pions là qui veille et qui empêche
les noirs de bouger les taux de maroc 6
qui produit souvent des parties
d'étouffement attention après calais les
deux cavaliers g6 maxime a replacé son
cavalier sur les droits pour un g3 à
noter que ce faisant il a libéré un
petit peu l'action de son fou puisque le
cavalier qui le gênait les parties la
tour des huit la tour maintenant rentrer
en jeu tour c'est un attention vis-à-vis
ici tour dames si vous poussez des cinq
prises et après un repli suffit de
prendre du cavalier indépendamment du
que le cab est sous emprise
puisque la tour attaquerait dans ce cas
là la dame acheter se pose la question
aux fous qui revient fous ces 5 propose
un échange de fou qui est accepté et il
reprend du pied en b s'intéressant le
pion contrôler la case importante ici
des 4 on pourrait ramener le cavalier e
set c6 et des quatre voilà il pourrait
revenir pour se replacer en d4
maintenant qu'il est protégé par un pion
ou de manière générale ce pion est très
bien contre la casse des quatre suffit à
ce que ce soit un but emblème placer un
pion qui était sur l'ale en v6
équivalent se rapproche du centre
c'est assez pas c'est pas mauvais c'est
même très bien f 4 pour les blancs alors
l'avantagé des blancs maintenant c'est
qu'après quatre peuvent envisager
peut-être de pousser au 5 et 2 d'avoir
une belle phalange de pions mais c'est
leur voix la d5 est possible maintenant
il ya plus de visas vis tour dames du
fait que le pion a repris cache un peu
l'action de la tour mais dans des scènes
qui est un conte libérateur avec
derrière un petit vis-à-vis tour dames
pour les noirs cette fois est donc faux
que les blancs choisissent ici donc
choisi de prendre une première fois ce
qui est bien bien sûr puisque ça libère
des cases pour le fou tout en libérant
des classes pour la tour donc ça c'est
un
cool dans tous les cas et après la
reprise les blancs mais sur ne se trompe
pas et jouent le très joli e senc avec
une très belle phalange de pions ici
très belle très belle ligne de pions à
noter quand même que le roi blanc est un
tout petit peu faible puisque il est un
peu dans les courants d'air maintenant
il ya plus de pions devant lui il peut
se faire plus tard prendre en échec sur
cette diagonale
ici il est sur la diagonale du fou sur
les cases blanches
attention à ça pour pour les blancs
maintenant qu'on à pousser les pions un
peu loin eu cinq attaques lecavalier au
bon moment c'est bien joué puisque si on
avait d'abord joué le cavalier sur scène
qu'il aurait pu venir avec la taille
peut pas ne pas venir e4 faut soit
prendre 26 et dans ce cas là faut
laisser faire aux qpr en c3 soit joué un
autre coin tout simplement
donc là les loups ont choisi un autre
coup qu'est ce qui se serait passé s'il
avait pris en f6 il faut quand même le
regarder quel noir mission est repris en
c3 on aurait pu prendre intermédiaire en
effet rangé cette ici c'est possible
attaquants la tour et fuite
parce que là faut bouger la tour les
blancs là le cavalier attaqué avec le
pion et la tour donc il faut simplement
voilà reprendre le pion très simplement
et maintenant le nord peuvent sans doute
continuer à faire un peu de pression
part d'amd si ce genre de coups avec
quand même voilà ils sont bien placés
sur les colonnes en train dé du jeu le
fou ici surtout très très fort si ce
qu'avaient les bouges l'attention à ce
que cette diagonale à devienne pas le
décanat le mortel
donc là il faut faire attention ici sans
doute les noirs ont l'initiative ici
dans cette position donc d4 l'oenb lente
pour ça ne rentre pas dans cette
variante tijuca ben ali à cap may donc
du coup il le concède au noir un pion
passé protéger protéger papillon ccnq ce
pion des quatre donc qu'à valider same
étonnant pour maxime et les blancs
prennent bien sûr le pion c5 et après
dans cette petit bilan les noirs ont
donné un pion à compter quatre ici 3 et
2 2 mais ils ont un pion passé soutenu
par une tour il est plus protégé par la
csn qui a sauté
il est soutenu par la tour donc c'est un
choix de dynamisme que café ici maxime
il a donné un pion pour voir dynamisme
dame c1
est-ce que ça va suffire c'est pas sûr
pour dames c'est rien ça c'est bien ça
mais l'aigle les pièces sur les la
colonne ici ou là clown ouverte si ce
cas les bouges tour ses sets gagnants
gagnerait le fou le fou 17 le fourbe et
cette dame 17 bouge pas le cavalier adam
17 met l'accent sur le cas il ya quatre
cas un problème mais simplement b3 alors
b3 le problème de b3 j'aime pas trop ce
coup puisque bien sûr ça protège le
cavalier mais ça affaiblit la casse ces
trois or le cavalier des scènes qu'il
aura maintenant la case de 3 lacasse c3
ce pion en fait on va jamais le bouger
parce qu'il est bien sûr cases noires
qui complète le fou qui attaquent les
cases blanches et il est aussi un
soutien sur deux cases pour le cavalier
des scènes où son collègue d'ailleurs
parce que le coeur léger 6 tôt ou tard
pour revenir en 7 et remplacer le
cavalier ça va être intéressant tour ses
huit fou f3 propose sans doute
d'échangés cette pièce dangereuse qui
peut sauter sur deux trois ou sur ces
trois à tout moment et c'est là que
maxime plante une petite combinaison
regard des très jolies cavale et c3 sans
doute un des moments clés de la partie
il a tendu mais ça marche
l'idée c'est qu'on coupe la défense de
la tour c cents par part la dame
donc ça peut créer des menaces il faut
que les noirs les blancs réagissent si
vous prenez le cavalier avec lecavalier
ça laisse la tourbe emprise donc les
noirs auraient agi correctement ils
prennent d'abord la tour s'est vite tout
reprend et maintenant ils prennent le
car il ya trois sinon il y avait menace
de calais prend à quatre avec la dame
qui attaque et en plus en double est là
simplement on reprend de la tour avec
pression sur la troisième rangée pour
les noirs
et maintenant en plus les fous son
vis-à-vis
donc là les blancs ne se trompe pas
qu'est-ce qu'on fait attention si vous
prenez vous laisser la dame emprise
après c'est possible de prendre
certainement faut prendre 17 et non il
n'a pas donc je dis n'importe quoi il ya
dame en prison peut pas prendre faits
sur donc après cabaye prend ses trois
tours princes et rois évidemment la dame
est attaqué il faut d'abord bouger la
dame à la et là la question qui se pose
est ce que les mots à richard jouve ont
laissé les les blancs échangés ici coc
maintenant que c'est au noir de jouer
qu'il faut faire attention et la maxime
joue sans doute le meilleur coût à mon
sens puisqu'il va replacer sa pièce qui
joue pas le cavalier là il peut pas
bouger
toutes les pièces sont actives ce tour
est active
on aurait pu envisager de jouer fois ci
ce qui pose une question la torre fun ou
invite les blancs jouer fou deux des
trois gagnerez du temps pour pousser le
pion je suis pas sûr que ce soit très
bien j'ai envie de laisser le pion sur
noir pour que le fonds puisse se balader
sur les cases blanches et ils jouent un
très joli coup très simple une fois
qu'on a fait cette remarque cavaliers ou
sept mois la très jolie puisqu'on va
envisager de venir soit 9,5 soit parfois
en d5 pour aller se glisser sur la casse
forte de trois protégés par le pion des
quatre et un filtre en gants blancs et
blanc sont sous pression ils ont quand
même un pion de plus pour la pression
donc la position d'être encore équilibré
vous prend dans prend les blancs
échanges de matériels mais les noirs
restent extrêmement actif à noter que ce
cas l'idée de tiennent tout cas bara
campe ce qui tient le pion b3 donc
malgré que dans mes tours attaque ses
pions ça tient et en plus ça contrôle
des cases blanches aussi une idée pas
mal ce cavalier
dames 2 les blancs sortent leurs dames
pour libérer peut-être que le passage de
la tour sur des uns pour bloquer le pion
1 sans doute et commencé à l'attaquer
aussi un mécanicien qui arrive tout de
suite
évidemment les noirs seraient très
contents que les blancs pouces g4 qui
est faiblir et un peu plus le roi le
clavier viendrai en étroite à quand la
tour et le pion
et créant tout un tas de menaces
notamment une menace de maths en g2
d'une menace ensuite deux tours c'est un
échec si la tour fait n'importe quoi
c'est dangereux pour les blancs donc les
blancs colmate voilà on colmate avec
dames 4 propose un échange de dames
attaquant le cavalier les noms auraient
pu garder les dames c'est possible ont
tous joué dans 17 protégeant le cas les
17 et évitant les changes et maxi n'a
pas peur de rentrer dans la finale
dimpre en cavale et prend on est en
partie rapide du rappel tour prend b3 il
a récupéré son pion le pion des quatre
reste protégé par le cavalier le roi est
toujours un peu en difficulté parce que
touré cavaliers mine de rien ça peut
créer des menaces sur la deuxième rangée
des choses un peu pénible donc et blanc
active leur tour à tour c'est un procès
de créer des contre menaces et peut-être
aussi contrôler le pion des avancées par
derrière c'est à dire un tour s'est vite
échec tour des huit et on empêche
d'avancer en se mettant sur sur la
colonne mais derrière le pion ce qui est
mieux que devant tomber de très bons
coups de maxime qui refuse de prendre le
pion à 3 pour venir créer de la pression
sur laurent blanc parce que très vite le
ce qu'allait devenir en 3d je peux en
échec en g2 obligé le roi allait venir à
agen et ensuite si je sors la tour je
peux me lasser des maths etc
pour s'éviter chèques des blancs quand
même on râle 7 et tour c'est cette
attaque à la fois le pion à cette
élection f7 un maxime joue encore tout à
fait précis tour deux chasses lecavalier
qui n'a pas de case de repli en c3 il en
profite pour le chasser maintenant pour
qu'ils bougent cavale et c5 et
maintenant regarder tour ces deux
clouage si les blancs si les blancs font
un coup comme cavalier à 6 qui était
l'un des rares coups qui enlève le
clouage il suffit pour les noirs de
détroit et problème gros problème pour
les blancs si tout reprend qui on prend
et la dame est impossible d'arrêter la
menace des blancs c'est de faire
tout simplement ici tout reprend kamal
et prend et des deux subi deux d un
échec avec de si les noirs les blancs
pardon joue ici le coup droit est fin et
mais ça marche pas suffit de jouer échec
et vous pouvez pas venir à un oui
regardez suroît a ignoré le magnifique
match superbe
regardez ce que j'avais dit tour sur la
deuxième avec un cavalier et un petit
pion qui traînent çà fait un très joli
mat
le roi est complètement vie c'est ici
peut pas sortir de ce de ce très joli
mat
donc après qu'elle csn tour ces deux
pose un gros problème au blanc menace de
jouer des trois on pourra pas prendre
puisque la tour seront prises si
j'enlève la tour c'est ce que vont faire
les blancs c'est ce qu'ont offert les
blancs psy n'y a pas d'autre solution en
fait donc là il semblerait que les
blancs se soit laissée déborder ici avec
notamment ce dernier coup peut-être
cavale et c c'est un quotidien parce que
après tours 2 il ya encore possibilité
de s'en sortir pour les jeunes y avait
un très joli coup de défense c'est
défensif mais ça tient
c'était de jouer le simple cavaliers f2
qui tient la baraque tout simplement
qu'elle est deux qui contrôle la case d3
important on peut pas pousser le pion
voilà et ici les noirs pu jouer cavalier
e3 menace échec et mat
mais dans ce cas là un simple coup comme
h3 et probablement suffisant surtout
rishek roi h2 et savaria pas on ne peut
pas faire maths avec que touré cavaliers
il faudrait qu'ils aient encore un petit
pion qui traîne quelque part ou ou une
pièce de plus mais là ça suffira pas
donc ça ne ferait que nul donc surtout
row 2 c'est là que l'erreur des blancs
cavalli 600 dans cette partie bon il
était sous pression et nous diront si le
pion des quatre centrales est sous
pression on l'a vu ça a permis au noir
de récupérer un pion et le roi blanc qui
s'aiment pas faibli voilà pour ces deux
gros coups de maxime ici et tout reprend
1,7 mais là il ya une combinaison
quasiment forcé parce que les noirs
jouent le très joli wife 6 qui à la fois
attaque la tour
laisse le cavalier emprise et on a vu
que six tours c'est cette détroit semble
tout gagné face elle même sur sagan tout
donc là les blancs n'ont pas le choix il
faut essayer de contre attaquer pour
essayer de sauver la partie et ils font
eux 6 voilà ils se disent bon mais je
vais essayer d'aller faire dame essayer
de créer un maximum de menaces je vais
pouvoir jouer j'ai quatre cavaliers
bouge f5 échec et j'ai encore des
menaces mais maxime a tout vu regardez
c'est le calculator tout reprend ses
cinq g4 ici de lederman donc ça c'est
fort c'est un tout ça cavalli ou trois
ans maintenant attention
pouf pouf je contrôle déjà ça si la tour
revient ici il peut y avoir des presque
matière pas de maths mais surtout le
pion on va pousser
regardez ici la menace des noix aussi
c'est de pousser wife 2 et b d2 quand
même parce qu'évidemment sur europe 1 en
cavale ignorer dames et laura peut pas
empêcher la nar et à tour non plus
puisque le cavalier contrôler la casse
de promotion donc les blancs pas le
choix faut continuer leurs attaques
f5 échec ah oui là il y avait un truc
sous les coups que n'a pas vu maxime
connu qu'il a choisi de ne pas jouer
pour pas prendre de risques sans doute
airois g5 intéressant voilà pour essayer
d'aller mater en fait simplement le roi
blanc mais les blancs auraient pu
pousser recette ici menaçant de faire de
faire dame tours 5
et là on peut prendre angers7 avec échec
avantage d'avoir poussé la tour on va
prendre ici aussi c'est qu'on peut pas
venir faire des chèques on est bloqué
par le canonnier est là avec le roi on
peut venir en h4 pour menacer de venir
en f3 pour menacer aussi de prendre le
simplement aussi en angers 4 et ça peut
menacer très vite des maths attention le
pion aussi qui quand il va faire échec
il fait math quasiment donc là si les
blancs jouent le coup f6 pour essayer
d'aller faire dame c'est possible
détroit dans ce cas-là f cette dame il y
aurait eu des deux est maintenant sur
dame simplement il ya dame subit du mat
1 par exemple dame ici pour les blancs y
aurait eu dame pour les noirs le roi est
obligé de venir en aide depuis ce que
sur dame f1 ya le cavalier qui
contrôlent donc il suffirait de faire
d'un prend et siro avec deux il y avait
simplement voilà dame et saint marc à la
fin
montréjeau limmat que n'a pas voulu les
nordmann donc sur f5 tchèque 3 sets
choisi maxime qui doit gagner aussi eu
cette peut-être un peu moins agressif
tours 5
voilà contrôle souvent c'est la même
idée on a poussé la tour à venir en 5 et
là on en profite maintenant pour faire f
6 puisque est bien le plus que j'ai
cette ecl oui les blancs attention les
blancs ici menace tout reprend rush 8f 7
et suroît prendre pour youri f8 dames
avec échec surtout reprend il y avait
encore une fille dames avec échec il ya
une menace des blancs extrêmement forte
il faut que les noirs et bien calculer
mais maxime a tout vu regarder les faits
le très joli voilà roigé seaska l'herbe
on s'attaque la tour surtout reprend on
va prendre et c'est bon on contrôler
l'arrivée du coeur est toujours une
pièce de plus sur qui on prend reprend
tour ça va mais les blancs ont joué un
coup qui peut faire peur puisque
regarder touré fuite de la part de
l'aisne norman menace bah oui de faire
dame alors qu'après vu maxime c'est là
qu'il fallait être précis
là bas il dit les sparages me faire dame
ainsi voilà celle de maxime g tu as
affaire d'âme mais moi aussi donc la
laine dorman d'abord pranger cette
menace de faire dame
on comprend il est là il aurait pu faire
dame mais dans ce cas-là tout reprend
regarder on va le faire c'est l'effet
dame s'était finie tout de suite et
dames simplement non repris tout reprend
et maintenant simplement d2 et surtour
d1 le seul coup pour empêcher tour des
huit le seul coup pour empêcher dames
ont fait d'armes quand même bien entendu
puisque le cavalier protège après tout
reprend car il prend en reste avec une
grosse pièce de plus dans une finale
gagnante 1 c'est un peu technique encore
mais c'est gagnant sans problème donc
croiser cette tour des huit fender
manning ne trompe pas pour empêcher pour
attaquer le pion et après tout prendre
cette tour prendre des trois cavale et
prend le g4 à la fin très bien venue de
maxime puisque ce cavalier regardez vous
allez voir bien qu'il puisse se faire
clouer il n'y a pas de problème là la
finale est techniquement gagnante parce
que la pièce de plus suffi à les gagner
le pion de plus qui va permettre de
gagner la fin donc les blancs tâte
encore tour g3 plus le cavalier
si vous faites tours 4 h3 et s'est
terminée vous allez repères dans la
pièce et la partie est pas clairement
gagnante du tout donc là les noirs
jouent h5 pour protéger et lens 10 mai
h3 et alors ça ça pose un problème
puisque je vais récupérer le cavalier
mais non maxime a tout vu ont regardé
tout aux trois très joli top 3 si vous
prenez mais sur avec le pion vous perdez
la tour si vous prenez la tour le
cavalier reprend et les plus attaquées
une pièce de plus si rien n'est gagné et
si vous faites le dernier coup qui c'est
de tenir un peu ça serait tour j'ai deux
possibles mais dans ce cas là les noirs
simplement prennent le pion à 3 ou
encore mieux bien entendu échec et mat
c'est encore mieux ce serait un échec et
mat
donc ça ne marche pas donc surtout aux
trois on est obligé d'échanger les tours
ou de jouets 3 g 2 on regarde quelques
coups si nous les rois g2 ici simplement
tour prend ra prend et on fait cavalier
5 les noirs pourraient faire ainsi
qu'elle est là on va attaquer le pion à
4 maintenant bloc le pion prochain coup
majeur auquel les baies de calais prend
et si les noirs prennent le pion ils
peuvent aller prendre le plus ancien
mais c'est par là regardez bien
cavalli les deux hommes on prend quand
même et après roy prend il suffit de
faire cavaler b6 et le roi ne peut pas
aller chercher le pion mais même s'il
avait pu il suffisait qu'il ne laissait
que s'il avait pu revenir il suffisait
de laisser que le carillon défense
lorraine ont achoppé le l'option pendant
que laurent blanc doit empêcher la dame
et ensuite il va aider à la promotion
on peut pas empêcher la promotion avec
un cavalier si ç'avait été un fou de
cases blanches oui mais c'est pas le cas
donc voilà donc après tour trois
abandons de lait normal et donc gros
points avec les noirs pour maxime
dans ce match il reste un maxime avec
les blancs maintenant d'assurer au moins
le nul pour pouvoir se qualifier en
huitièmes de finale sachant que carsen
cramique ou encore nakamura se sont fait
éliminer il ya il a une belle
opportunité maxime maxime là pour aller
vraiment loin dans cette coupe du monde
il est déjà loin
il n'est pas encore qualifié en huitième
mais s'il arrive en huitième il va faire
partie quand même des gros favoris
maintenant ça va se jouer à peu de
choses nous rappelle son objectif c'est
d'aller au moins en finale mais sur
gagner la coupe s'il peut la gagner mais
on un final pour se qualifier pour le
cycle prochaine le championnat du monde
pour le tournoi des candidats qui lui
permettrait de viser le titre le titre
mondial qui est maintenant son objectif
affiché un un maximum alors avant qu'on
passe à la deuxième partie de ce match
propose à une petite annonce quand même
sur sur diagonale tv donc je vous
rappelle le site assez de gala des gones
al tv points.com et bien entendu cette
semaine si vous regardez début septembre
2010 est cette vidéo et bien il y aura
le circuit diagonale tv qui va aller
filmer le fameux tournoi de chartres mal
à chartres l'est donc une petite
promotion pour le tournoi de chartres
tourna blitz btp jl c'est donc le 16
septembre d'abord donc c'est un r'n'b
rapide et blitz donc d'abord un tournoi
de blitz qui sera retransmis en vidéo
sur des modèles tv et enfin aussi le
lendemain il y aura le 17 septembre donc
toujours en direct sur des modèles tv en
direct de chartres vous aurez donc
l'espace à l'espace soutine à lèvres qui
est à côté de chartres c'est chartres
métropole même qui fait partie de
chartres métropole et donc il y aura un
rapide de cette ronde 15 minutes plus 5
secondes avec donc un bis la veille
voilà donc et vous pouvez retrouver les
les grands tournois filmer ces dernières
années notamment dans le xi 2000 2010
est ainsi 2016 mais d'ici 2017 qui était
aussi en rapide et blitz ainsi que le
championnat de france rapide féminin sur
diagonale tv.com voilà n'oubliez pas
d'aller sur le site puisque des monnaies
diffusé sur plusieurs chaînes donc il
faut faut pouvoir suivre depuis le site
si vous voulez être au courant des
directs voilà donc c'était un petit
petites annonces importantes pour notre
très beau tournoi de chartres et tombe
en france et voilà que du canal tv va
essayer de mettre en valeur cette saison
sur le circuit
donc on va revenir maintenant notre
match
après cette petite pause maxime donc
aller blanc il a gagné la première il
faut arriver à faire au moins nul dans
la seconde pour se qualifier pour les
huitièmes c'est parti pour maxime avec
eux quatre ces cinq cas bf3 e6 des
quatre qui comprend qu'elle les prend à
6 et là il pourrait presque je vous la
même partie ici avec ses 4 un an maxime
l'espèce de gambie maroc sicap a réussi
deux des taux de maroussi qui n'a pas
réussi à la normale cavaler c3i de
varier quand même s'il fait pas la même
chose dans dames c'est cette fois 2006
petit rock très classique la foulée 4
attention
évidemment menace peu fou prend
comprendre d'apprendre et les blancs
s'en moque il espère avec l'idée vous
allez voir d'affaiblir les noirs après
fou prend il le fait quand lederman il
faut qu'ils gagnent donc voilà il faut
qu'il tente le tente le coup il ya fou
prend ici ce qui a été fait qu' on prend
et maintenant pions princes et rois et
noir prennent l'option de plus mais il
va en gros retard de développement un
petit rohff qui va être très dangereux
et maxime va continuer avec tourbe et un
très joli coup très simple la pression
sur bessette on peut pas jouer b6 si on
joue beceem gct c'est possible de tenter
bessengue mais on risque d'affaiblir ça
va ça va être difficile pour pour les
noirs simplement voilà il fait plutôt
cavaliers c6 pour commencer à sortir les
pièces et simplement pas perdre de temps
maxime prend aussi six prises du pion
des pour les noirs et maintenant tour b3
active la tour sur la troisième non
seulement on continue de faire pression
sur bessette
si le football jean bessette on 17 on
prendra en 17 mai la tourbe à pouvoir
coulisses et m6 voilà ce que cette
fameuse troisième rangée et
éventuellement aussi permettre un
doublement de tours on va pouvoir
doubler sur le col b soit sur la colonne
des plus tard la dame s'en bat et là un
très joli coup de maxime
j'aime beaucoup ce coup d'amendés de
voilà simplement permet la tour et fin
de venir en bus soit en d1 souvent bien
même sans doute en d1 puisque c'est là
qu'est la colonne ouverte alors que là
bas après b5 maintenant qu'on a joués
hors prix du pillon des imbéciles
bloqueurs est complètement la colombe
est donc plutôt la colonne des qui est
ouverte pour menacer d'aller en demi
teinte faire quasiment le match
or or noir pourquoi pas si on arrivait à
mettre les trois tours les trois pièces
lourdes les tours et la dame sur cette
colonne c'est maintenant faisable et
secoue aussi que j'aime beaucoup en d2
et d3 puisque bien sûr il n'empêche pas
la tour de coulisser et ils contrôlent
la diagonale noirs ici les deux
diagonales noirs ici de cases noires
alors que le fou lui contrôler les cases
blanches
regardez le faisceau la de diagonale
contrôlé par la dame une foule ici quand
le fou de cases noires a disparu la dame
vient souvent le remplacer sur sur les
sur les diagonales
donc c'est un coup très intéressant e5
alors même idée ici bas ici c'est les
pions qui se mettent sur cases noires et
le fou qui a envie de se mettre à 1,6
pour contrôler les cases blanches c'est
sans doute un bon coup mais tour des 1
attention le nas échec et mat
alors si vous faites le petit rang
qu'ici c'est sans doute extrêmement
dangereux on peut regarder un peu pour
voir pourquoi c'est dangereux ici petit
rock très simplement il y aurait un math
forcé regard des tories tchèques 3 h 8
forcé sinon photo de foule et c'était
une bonne idée et maintenant damage 6
menace dame g7 maths et là il ya un seul
coup un c'est tour j'ai vite et là
simplement par exemple pour faire d'un
prendre il ya plein de trucs possibles
mais dans prend ici suffit et après tout
les sept y aura d'un projet 7 mat
voilà donc après tour des 1 vous pouvez
par ok donc il faut fait faire un coup
de repli par dams est hélas maxime joue
un bon coup puisqu'ils jouent autour des
3 la menaçant le fameux
matt en 18 maintenant même idée si vous
rauque et c'est la même manoeuvre il y
aura match de la même façon ah on peut
essayer quand même en garde et alice est
pas tout à fait pareil puisque la quasi
fils ici protégé par la dame alejo marre
parce que c'est comme des combinaisons
de match quand même pas mal menace a
touché 3 suivi de maths angers7
on croise celui de forcer tour j'ai
trois menaces toujours un match ici donc
tour g8 et forcé et maintenant on ferait
encore la même chose après tout reprend
on va prendre
hop là deuxième tour bien coulissé et
comment vous empêchez tour g3 suivi du
mat
et bien vous pouvez pas sur roy a suit
tour g3 et la dame peut pas venir un
fluide puisque la torah mythe est coupée
voilà donc après tour des 3 il faut
réagir simplement voilà faut aussi et
c'est fini ses protégés on peut par ok
donc le prochain coup des blancs est
très jolie dame à 6 et le roi est bloqué
voilà les blancs réussi mais les blancs
laisse le pion à de même noter la dame
h6 empêche empêche l'europe sur damas
fuite pour cette chasse et l'adami on
est dans le pré m6 qui perd un pion sa
perdra d'ailleurs le pion 5 ça c'est une
catastrophe donc ici les noirs jouent un
joli coup ça sans doute un des meilleurs
coups
donc j'ai vite voilà pour essayer de
s'activer on va cette chasse et la dame
sans doute partagé six ou en tout cas on
commence à faire un peu de un peu de jeu
voilà bon mais ça laisse le pion à cette
emprise mais sur hélas les blancs avec
avait un très joli coup que n'a pas vu
maxime ici semble-t-il c'est fou h5 qui
est pas mal ça cloue le pignon of 7
l'europe a toujours pas bougé et ça
empêche détour g6 l'aurait jamais tour
g6 à cause du fou ou alors si mais il
faut rendre la calypso donné la qualité
et mais ça voilà donc ce ce coût était
très fort parce que les noirs ont pas
vraiment de coup ici possible
c'est ça devient ça devient très dur
imaginez ici que les noirs parisiens
prennent le pion à 210 heures mais j'ai
dû contre eux je vais pouvoir pousser à
et c'est maintenant d'un proche est le
la tourbe hâte de voir revenir en
en fuite fou g4 et je menace tour des 7
je menace fou échec froide et 8 fou aux
six échecs de la tour et ensuite je
prendrai le x 2 des choses comme ça
beaucoup de menaces les noirs seraient
obligés de revenir en 6 et là on peut
simplement prendre sans doute après puis
on prend dans prend reprend-il retour
des cet échec le roi tout lui de venir
en 8 et hop on prend 2,17 et risque
d'avoir la deuxième tour qui va pénétrer
et il n'y a pas de contre eux je
possible pour les noirs les tours sont
coupés c'est pas bon du tout donc tour
j'ai vite ils voient parfois cinq maximy
fait un coup que plus tendancieux il
fait tour des six tours déçu c'est un
peu tendancieux les noms avant que tu
joue ici un joli coup intéressant il l'a
pas vu l and german non plus fous des
cinq qui coupent voilà s'accoupler tour
sa menace d'un pro tour si vous faites
qui comprend il ya dame prend tour là il
ya une possibilité de s'en sortir par on
peut sans doute faire dame prend tour
prend peut-être tout reprend m6 sait on
de voir ce qui se passe sur troupe round
6 la latte aurait sauvé mais voilà les
noirs maintenant prennent le pion
le 4 le pion et cette veille à panneaux
tour aussi ce n'est pas de clouage et il
semblerait créé noir ça soit sorti
maintenant il ya eu quatre assortis il
n'y a plus on va pouvoir jouer peut-être
sous des cinq derrière faut 6 on peut
peut-être joué tour des huit aussi pour
se libérer
c'est plus du tout la même partie donc
je ne vois pas les nordmann ce coup il
n'a pas envie de le faire pour x raisons
après tour des six veux pas je me fous
des scènes effet d'un v8 bon qui est
sans doute un peu mon bon et blanc
gardent l'avantagé on rappelle qu'il
suffit de la partie nulle pour maxime
pour se qualifier d'emprunt m6 les noirs
sont toujours sur une pression terrible
la menace des blancs ces deux fermes at
on des huit dames 7 et d'un prince a
choisi de prendre un sens c'est un bon
coup là les noirs auraient pu encore
sans doute joué food et 5 puisqu'après
d'en prendre à prendre la tête la tour
et ensuite on va prendre le pion aux 4
on aurait peut-être pu aussi peut-être
prendre le pion à 2 le demande pour les
noir sans doute c'était aussi jouable
quoique les blancs doivent rester muet
après d'emprunt on reprend tour échec
qui ramassent youtube et 7 ou alors près
d'am preuve six dames 7
mais prendre un 5 e maxime et là ils
attention il ya un coût que qu'il avait
sans doute pas vu alors c'est une partie
rapide du rappel
regardez boom de länder man tout reprend
g2 ou la mauvaise nouvelle sirois prend
fou échec
h3 reprend h3 et vous perdez la dame
donc vous pouvez encore joué roi h1
c'est ce que fait maxime mais il n'avait
sans doute pas vu son coût sinon maxime
n'aurais pas appris le pion aux scènes
qu'il aurait joué plus sagement
maintenant les noms revient dans g8 mais
du coup le roi est beaucoup plus faible
pour les blancs et ça va jouer un rôle
bien entendu faux h5 quand même des
blancs clou le pion à vii et menacent
tout reprend aussi si bien entendu
puisque sur dame priori d'emprunt échec
et on peut pas reprendre du pied donc
attention pour les noms et les noirs le
coût est quasiment forcé voilà royal
fuite évite le clouage maintenant
surtout bien sûr on peut prendre de la
dame sans problème ce qui a plus de
courage il a un maximum avait encore un
joli coup ici qui n'a pas vu c'est les
parties rapides je vous rappelle un coup
intéressant tout simple regard des tours
j ai tout simplement la tour n'a pas de
case en justice il ya le fou donc vous
perdez la qualité ans a chuté à la dame
il faudrait prendre ici on gm et après
roy prend les normes des problèmes
puisqu'il ya la menace des blancs c'est
de faire damas huit échecs ramasse la
tour la torah 8 et c'est surtout matin
si on fait rien avec le nord c'est matt
le seul coup qui tient la partie
ses parois 8 puisque vous perdez tout il
y aurait tout reprend
vous pouvez pas reprendre du pian à
cause du cloud âgées de la dame il y
avait d'un cran et il ya toujours le
clouage donc ici faudrait rejouer roi g8
est là simplement fou g4 avec clouage du
fou et si les noirs défendre de manière
passive comme par tour et 8 c'est
possible mais dans ce cas là il suffit
de faire fou prend qui on prend et après
tour des 3 il ya un problème ce roi est
trop faible
you a touché 3 est mortelle voilà qu'est
ce que vous faites ici vous pourrez une
ferme êtes obligé de jouer h6 pour
donner un peu des rois et après un coup
comme tours j'ai trois ou damage 5
encore mieux attaque le pion vous pouvez
par année la dame en défense puisque la
tour est en prise aussi donc le seul
coup c'est sans doute de jouer roi h7
tôt que j'ai trois menaces d'am-dam g63
je suis dedans prend 1,6 avec un gain
rapide il n'ya matap et pas d'amis six
échecs
donc là il faudrait jouer ici très
certainement tour g8 il a après tout
reprend reprend dans prend 1,6 et les
blancs ont un pion de plus en finale de
dame ce pion h qui peut filer et là nul
est largement à portée des blancs il
fait même partie ghanem gros avantage
bleus en finale quoi très difficile à
défendre
mais maxime rentre pas là-dedans prix
roi et fuites donc ils avouent ils
voient pas tout retour j'ai un ff iv
faux h3 et là on va avoir droit
maintenant à une grosse finale lente
parce que là le roi blanc ont regardé il
est toujours sous pression ici les noirs
propose un échange de dames
maxime saute sur l'occasion ou apprend
et maintenant fouet 3 voilà pour éviter
toute pénétration la menace du nord
c'était maintenant devenir avec tours g2
attaqué la deuxième rangée avec une
partie qui reste encore compliqué tu
auras des 8 propose un échange ils vont
rentrer en finale parce que les blancs
menacé de jouer f5 qui couplent fou sans
doute pour jouer tour des sept échecs
ramasser les pions de l'ale dame pour
prendre pour prendre convoi prend et
c'est une finale regarder le très joli
coup de maximy si on se précipite pas
relâchés voilà très important d'aller
très vite ramener le roi au centre en
finale il faut que toutes les pièces
jouent les fous peuvent se balader vite
pas le roi donc les rangs il faut lire à
manille
vite vers le centre droit c'est cette
eau avec 2 3 des 6 3 août renvoyer comme
les coups droits sont chaîne des deux
côtés roy c5 juste à temps empêche de
jouer roi des 4 pour les blancs et le
roi met un peu de pression sur les pions
de l'ale d'amis si mes deux pions
contraint ici pour les blancs qui ont
potentiellement un pion passé rapide ici
alors que celui des noirs est beaucoup
plus lent à se mettre en route
x 2 empêche le roi blanc de venir sur la
case c4 donc il peut venir sur la case
b4 ça c'est possible mais sur roy b4
probablement ici les blancs auraient
joué
regardez très simplement f sec avec une
grosse menace qui serait imaginé que les
noirs jouent au roi ici c'est 3
maintenant regardez la bourse menace
c'est celle là c'est de jouer au f4 ou
3g de f3 peut-être wife 4,4 et si
possible et on va pousser leurs pions
pour aller à dame aux menaces aussi roi
g3 qui prend le fond c'est surtout ça la
menace moi j'ai trois prend le fou ça ça
obligerait ici et s'il vous s'en va ça
augmente la la pression pour les blancs
pour aller faire une dame madame rapide
donc après fou 2 c'est pas facile pour
les noirs d'aller jouer web et 4 parce
que ses pions vont vite et le full un
peu se faire enfermer donc b5 et
ficelles quand même
pareil la menace haye et maxime a vu
cette menace menaceront f2 le fou n'a
pas de gaz tout est pris et ensuite 3g
trois organes le font donc f6 pour les
noirs là il aurait pu il aurait pu
tenter mais attention les noirs vous
peuvent aussi attaquer vite les pions
ici notamment qui ont un et il peut y
avoir des pions passé aussi des deux
côtés mais là ça va être quand même très
bon de jouer au f4 ici un il aurait pu
quand même là même s'il joue un autre
coupe en plus prudents sans doute ces
trois tout simplement voilà on empêche
le roi noir de passer c'est plus facile
à calculer je rappelle qu'il a besoin
que d'une nulle donc pas de problème
pour maxime garde bien de tenir sa son
16e de finale la maintenance ou g2
roy f4 ça y est on va créer le temps
passer roy dès 6 h 4 ont toujours les
pions sur noirs ici ici sur blain ça
empêche le fou de jouer et le pion sur
noir ici très important mais sûre pour
pas se le faire prendre par le fou
adverse
ces cinq pour les noirs qui vont essayer
de ce crime qui ont passé fou des trois
c4 intact le fou fou et 2 à 5 pour les
noirs qui continue de jouer pour le gain
est il faut ils n'ont pas le choix de
toute façon pour rejouer pour je devais
4 à 3 en pêche
voilà c'est ça va pas être possible h 6
pour les noirs on verrouille ici tout
passage du roi même si cinq plus tard
après pris ce prisme
mais le pion 115 morts en tout cas fois
je saigne des blancs menace de venir en
1/8 pour attaquer à regarder comme le
foulard peut pas venir défendre s'il y
en ait failli contrôle pas il vérifie
quand même fff pour un simple coup date
en chine une sorte de coup d'attendre
fou 1,8 et vous n'avez pas le temps de
faire au roi c5 y aurait eu cinq qui on
prend comprend roi prend pardon et
ensuite f6 f7 et les noix après avoir
plus si on pousse ensuite il a pris ce
prix ce prise et le four amène attaque
le pion final c'est un peu ce qui va se
passer d'ailleurs b4 les noirs ici ça
apprend à noter qu'on peut pas jouer à
quatre qui nous intéresserait pas ce
qu'elle fout apprend s'éprend et ses
trois bons mais les noirs ici d'aller à
dame mais bon ça va quand même pas être
possible
fou à quatre voies la contrôler la case
ces deux sous des trois est juste à
temps bien sûr whaou 3 maintenant si
vous faites ces deux et bien monsieur
possible en haillons on peut regarder
imaginons que les que les noirs face ces
deux sont surtout pas prendre le fleuret
dames ont donc simplement roi des deux
est sûre fou prend 2,4 juste à temps fou
prend ces deux qui protège le pion
obscènes et les blancs avec en plus avec
sans doute une partie gagnante ici donc
fou des trois rois 3 faut pas jouer
assez 2 mai fu b1 menace
rien puisque sur ces deux il y aura
quand même rodez de bayssan qu alors
l'idée de jouer b5
c'est d'éloigner le renoir des
opérations sera obligé toujours de
rester dans ce coin est donc il peut pas
s'occuper des pions de l'autre côté et
donc on va avoir un qui ont passé qui
avance hélas ici la possibilité que ces
plans avancent qu'ils vont créer un
deuxième tueur passé ces cinq au cnc le
seller mais justement et après pions
prend hexis menace f7 pour les adam le
seul coup c'est dans le péché parce que
si vous y allez avec le roi l'autre
qu'on va avancer et maintenant regarder
pousser de hauts bien sûr puisque sur
fou prend 7,7 et maintenant fou détroit
protège le pion vous pouvez jouer ces
deux fous prend on va prendre mais après
trois ou quatre rois prend les biens ont
toujours un point de plus dans trois des
six faux 4 contre la casse b737 5 fu des
trois rois b6 re 4 maintenant pour les
blancs fuji six échecs roi prend 1,5
quand même
il a tout vu maxime regarder après faut
prendre des trois qui gagnent le fou
mais il ya quand même qu'ils ont passés
qui filent f7 les noirs aussi ces deux
est fluide dames c'est en dame mais mais
mais si on doit de jouer juste à temps
dans des six échecs et roy prendre
bessec dame prendre des trois échecs les
noirs accepte la partie nul ici bon
c'est nul cette façon c'est foutu ils
peuvent rien faire il valoir que des
échecs tout le temps les blancs cassés
ingagnable pour les noirs ça de toute
façon donc dame c4 après dun prend on va
prendre la partie va être nul après le
roi m6 trois des cinq roger 6,6 euros
apprend simplement regarder ici nulle
valait toujours combien de la nulle si
ici les noirs aurait simplement dû jouer
sans doute le simple droit edd 6 et ce
roi h7 rang ex est maintenant sûr h5
simplement nathan si le roi sort on
vient en g8 et on peut pas faire
d'annoncé est maintenant c'est fini
si vous faites ça vous êtes bloqués
voilà et si vous si vous voulez éviter
ça sera f7 si vous faites h5 voilà roi
et suite si vous faites 3 h 6 ici ça
c'est une autre possibilité simplement
regarder à roye g8 il apprécie
suite tac on pousse et voilà et c'est ça
va être pas tous est obligé de venir '
1,6 avec ici une partie nulle aussi donc
c'est pourquoi après roi m6 soit des
cinq volets 6-2 6-3 prend 1,6 et bien
maxime propose la partie nulle et les
deux joueurs combien décide de la partie
nulle qui qualifie donc maxime pour les
huitièmes de finale de cette coupe du
monde bravo aux français voilà il
t'arrive est déjà assez loin et faut
viser maintenant l'écart
bien entendu en huitièmes en espérant
que bombay il sera toujours en forme et
qu' il sera à l'abri de la de la fameuse
gaffe qu'il faut éviter
comme disait laurent frayssinet le jeu
d'échecs et cruelle ont peu joué
magnifiquement pendant quarante coups et
au 41e faire une énorme faute qui met
tout par terre
et bien c'est pareil dans un tournoi
extrêmement difficile d'aller au bout
d'un internaute de ce type là mais pour
l'instant il est bien parti
notre numéro 2 français notre numéro
deux mondial et numéro 1 français maxime
vachier lagrave
merci à bientôt donc sur des zones
activées pour la suite de cette coupe du
monde fis dès 2017
au revoir